The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Let's get started.
So today we're going to talk
about Android security, which
is-- you can sort of think
of it as an interesting case
study of a system
that was designed
with quite a bit
of attention paid
to security in the first place.
So this is perhaps in contrast
to many of the systems
we've looked at
so far, like Unix,
or the web, browsers,
where security
was in many ways bolted
on after the fact
and wasn't really designed
in quite the same way
as you see in this paper,
where these guys who
designed the Android
were very worried
about particular
classes of attacks,
and constructive mechanisms.
Then figured out a better way
of structuring applications
that is going to allow us
to enforce security policies
in a better way in Android.
And the cool thing about
it is that it's actually
a pretty widely used system.
So unlike some
research papers that
might propose a
new architecture,
this actually gets
used in practice.
And there's lots and lots of
Android devices out there.
And we can talk about how well
some things have worked out,
how well some things
didn't pan out.
But we will, I
guess, look at what
parts of the design they
thought were important,
what did they miss, what,
in practice, turns out
to matter or not.
But it's kind of interesting.
In some ways, it also
uses existing systems
that we've talked about.
So Android is built
on top of Unix.
It's just a Linux kernel running
underneath the entire phone.
So in many ways, they use some
of the familiar mechanisms
you guys have seen
in Lab 2 already,
where you use Unix user IDs
and groups and all these things
to separate applications
from one another.
But in Android's case, they
have a very different way
of setting up user IDs
and file permissions,
et cetera, than in a
typical Linux system.
So I guess let's
start out by talking
about what is the threat level?
What are these guys
worried about on a phone?
What's going on?
What are they trying
to protect against?
What's the threat model?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Applications that
want to do malicious things?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So they worry
about-- I guess there
was these applications that
are going to run on the phone.
And they might be malicious.
And I guess there's-- well,
that there's outright malicious
applications that are
just out to get you,
maybe steal your private data.
So things you might worry
about-- there's data,
there's things that
might cost money,
like sending an SMS message
maybe, or making a phone call.
There's maybe using the
internet, et cetera.
So these are the,
presumably, things
you want to guard against
or protect on your phone.
And then there's
things that go wrong.
So presumably, there's
malicious applications,
because these guys want to
allow users to install apps
written by developers
that Google has never
heard of themselves.
Or it might be that apps just
have bugs themselves, that you
have a well-meaning
developer, but they
forget to do something.
And it would be nice
to help these guys
as well to build applications
that remain secure
despite the fact that
the app developer isn't
an expert in exactly every
kind of vulnerability
that might be exploited
in their application.
So one thing we could
do is, actually, we
can-- because Android
is what we use,
we can look at various
vulnerability reports.
So there's this
database called CVE
that catalogs lots of
common vulnerabilities
in software systems.
And it's actually
kind of interesting.
There is a number of reports,
of course, of bugs in Android.
And many of them are of the
flavor you guys have already
seen in the class.
So there's still
buffer overflows
in some parts of Android.
There's bad default
choices for crypto systems.
People forget to initialize
the random number
generator sometimes and
generate predictable keys.
So all these things
do still happen.
It's software.
It's not immune from any
of the other problems
we've seen so far.
But one cool thing
is that there doesn't
seem to be a huge
number of these issues.
So they crop up
from time to time.
But by large, can
fix these issues.
And the system remains
reasonably secure
after you fix these bugs.
So in many ways,
this, I think, design
is working reasonably well.
So we'll look at it, I guess,
in more details later on as
to which parts of the design
are working to various degrees.
But it seems to be a reasonably
well thought out design.
Or at least much more so than
desktop Unix applications
that you've seen so far.
All right.
So maybe one way to approach
this is to figure out
how we're going to protect
data and various services
that might cost you
money, et cetera,
from malicious applications
is first to understand
what does an application look
like in an Android system.
And then we'll talk about
how various permissions
or privileges are configured in
that application and enforced.
So Android applications are
quite different from what
you've seen so far in terms
of desktop apps or web
applications.
So instead of being
a monolithic piece
of code with a main function
that you start running,
and you just keep
going forever, they're
actually much more modular.
And the application, in the
case of Android, is-- actually,
you can think of it as a
collection of components.
And the paper talks about
four kinds of components
that the Android
framework provides to you
or gets the developer
to think in terms of.
And the components
are roughly-- there's
something called an activity.
You might have an
activity component.
And this is just a thing
that has a user interface.
So these are things that
actually display things
to the user, or take
user input, touches,
key presses, et cetera.
In terms of security,
the Activity thing
has an interesting security
property that you probably
want to make sure your
user input is going
to one activity at a time.
So the framework-- I believe
[? an ?] Android actually
ensures that there is only
one activity that's getting
your user input at a time.
So if you are running
your bank application,
you can be reasonably
confident that there's not
other applications in the
background grabbing the screen
presses corresponding to your
PIN number in your bank app.
So having the framework be aware
of these different activities
helps enforce some security
properties with respect
to user input.
All right.
So these guys are the
user interface components
of an application.
And then there's
three other types
of components that mostly
help an application
structure its own sort
of logic and interaction
with other components.
So there is something
called a service component.
And this guy just runs
in the background.
So you might have
a service component
that monitors your location,
like in the application
these guys describe
in the paper.
Or you might have
services that pull things
from the network in the
background, et cetera.
These guys have a content
provider component.
And you can think of
these guys as just SQL
database you can define.
Or you can define
a couple of tables
with a schema, et cetera.
And you can run SQL
queries all over the data
stored in that application.
And having it be a
component is going
to allow the framework
to control access
to this database to say
who's allowed to run queries
against it.
And then there's
something kind of unusual
that hasn't shown up in other
systems-- something called
a broadcast receiver.
And this guy is going to be
used for receiving messages
from other parts of the system.
So we'll talk about how
applications interact with one
other in terms of messages.
All right.
So this is some very
high-level logical view
of how you can think of
an Android application.
But in reality, all these are
just Java classes or Java code
that the developer writes.
And there's just some standard
interface for an activity,
for a service, for a
broadcast receiver,
for a content provider
that you implement.
But clearly, this is
all just Java code.
And this application box is
really just a Java runtime
that runs on top of your phone.
And it's just a single
process on the Linux
kernel running on your phone.
And all these
components are just
different classes or pieces
of code running inside
of this Java runtime process.
That make sense?
That's how it sort of translates
to traditional processes
that you might
understand otherwise.
And the other thing that sort
of shifts with an application
is what's called a manifest.
So this is code that the
application developer
writes or compiles.
But there's also
this manifest that
sits on the side, which
is a text or an XML file,
really, that describes
all these components
and how other
parts of the system
should interact with
this application.
So in particular,
this manifest is
going to talk about
things called labels
that we'll talk about
in a second that
define both the privileges
of this application in terms
of what it should
be allowed to do
as well as the
restrictions on who else
should be able to interact
with the different components
of this application.
That make sense?
Questions about how that works?
AUDIENCE: Is the
label something like,
this app cannot do the phone
call, or this app can send--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So these labels are
going to be things
like, well, this application
can dial a phone,
or can send an SMS message,
or can use the internet.
So there's really
two kinds of labels.
So we can draw them out here.
So each application
has a list of labels
that describe the privileges
that the application has.
So these are something
like maybe DIAL PERMISSION
for dialing a phone,
maybe INTERNET, et cetera.
So we'll talk about how they're
described in a little bit.
So these are privileges
that the application has.
But then you can
also stick labels
on top of individual components.
And there, they have
a different meaning.
So these are privileges
that the application has.
If you have a label
[? on a ?] component,
it's a requirement
on anyone that
talks with the component to
have the corresponding label.
So in their example,
maybe you have some sort
of a FRIEND VIEW privilege.
So you are able to view the
locations of your friends.
So that's like a privilege you
might have in an application.
So you're allowed to do this.
But then in order to
enforce this privilege,
you might actually put
this FRIEND VIEW label
onto a particular component.
So you might say, well, my
content provider, the database
storing the location
of all my friends,
might have the FRIEND
VIEW label attached to it.
And what this means
is that anyone that
wants to access
this database better
have this label in
their privilege set.
So that's how you
specify permissions.
You can think these are as like
generalized user IDs or group
IDs from Unix, except
they're arbitrary
strings, which make them
slightly more flexible.
You don't run out of these guys.
You don't worry
so much about who
gets the number 25 or
silly things like that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So turns out these guys
aren't-- at least in the design,
weren't super careful in
scoping these guys out.
So you could totally have
two applications that decide
to introduce the same label.
So these labels are
application-defined, partly.
And you could have
two applications,
like Facebook and Google+.
They say, oh, we
want to both create
a new permission string that's
View Your Friends In A Social
Network.
All right.
Well, they're the same string.
So by convention,
what happens is
that these strings
are actually longer
than what I am drawing out.
And they have the domain
of the Java-style domain
of the application
defining it in the string.
So DIAL PERM, I
think, is actually
something like
com.google.android.dialperm.
I might have slightly
screwed this up.
But roughly, these are
the kinds of strings
that show up in permissions.
So if you have
well-meaning applications,
then they won't collide in terms
of these permission strings.
But it turns out
that nothing actually
enforces this,
unfortunately, in Android.
So you do have some
potential problem
that arise as a result
of this, that-- I don't
know why they weren't fixed.
It's a little bit
tricky to fix them.
Maybe these guys
thought, well, let's
do them now, [? for ?]
maybe they weren't
thinking of these issues.
Anyway.
So we'll see what
arises if you have
two applications that conflict
on the label names that we get.
All right.
Make sense?
So this is what a single
application looks like.
It's a bunch of Java code,
a manifest describing
the permissions for
the application,
and the required restrictions
on all the components.
And then in order to communicate
between applications,
for the most part, it's
done through what's
called an intent,
which is an Android
thing that the developers of
this framework introduced.
And an intent-- you can think
of it as a structured message
that-- we'll see how these
components of an intent
are going to be
used in a second.
But roughly, the intent
has three important things.
There's other fields, of course.
But the main thing is the name
of a component to which you
want to send a message.
There's the action that you
want the component to take
and the data, along
with a MIME type,
that you want to send
to this other component.
So just as an example--
this is a little abstract--
but what you can imagine is
that this component is maybe--
you could imagine
com.android.dialer/Dial
or something.
So this is how you name
a component in Android.
You specify the name
of the application,
which is kind of like this
Java inverted domain name.
Like, com.android.dialer
is the name
of an overall
application to which you
want to send an intent.
And then you write
something like /Dial.
And Dial is the
name of a component.
Would [? lend ?] that
target application to which
you are sending this message.
OK.
So that's how you name
the particular component
where you want to send the guy.
The action, there's a
predefined set of actions.
You could stick in your
own things as well.
But you might have
something like, I think,
android.intent.DIAL.
So this is a pre-defined string
or, by convention, a string
that applications put
on the Action field
if they want the phone dialer
to dial a phone number for them.
So this is how you
stick something in here.
There's other actions.
Like, if you want
to view a document,
you will stick something.view
in the Action field.
This'll tell the
receiving component
that you just want to
view this object instead
of dialing the phone number
that's in the object, perhaps.
And finally, the
data is basically
an arbitrary URI
or URL for the data
that you want to send
along with this message.
So it could be something like
a telephone, colon, some digits
to dial the phone number.
It could be an actual HTTP URL
that you want to view or open.
It might be any
other applications
you find URI as well.
So this is how you
send these messages.
And the way these
messages are actually
routed through the system is
with the help of the Android
runtime itself that
sits underneath all
these applications.
So you can think of
the Android runtime
as being somewhere between the
applications and the kernel.
It's not quite
correct, but maybe
let's try to draw some
picture to clarify
what the architecture of
this thing looks like.
So you have one application
that's running on Android.
Perhaps you have
another application.
These are all boxes
that are basically
these guys-- a
separate application
with a bunch of
components internally.
Of course, these guys
are all processes running
on top of the Linux kernel.
So that's providing
some degree of isolation
between the applications.
And then there's what the paper
calls the reference monitor.
And this guy is
going to mediate all
the intent-level interactions
between the different apps
here.
So if App 1 wants to
send a message to App 2,
they actually are going to
send a message to the reference
monitor first.
So this is how you send
all intents in Android,
is that you create one
of these intent messages.
And you basically send it over
some pipe to this reference
monitor.
So Android basically has
its own implementation
of pipes for sending these
kinds of intents, called binder.
And every Android
application, by convention,
is going to open a
binder connection over
to the reference monitor,
so the reference monitor
can get intents from
this application
as well as send messages
over to this application.
So in our case, if App 1
writes an intent for App 2
to the reference monitor,
the reference monitor
is going to figure out where
this intent should go and relay
it over here to App 2.
So Application 2 can
maybe start an activity,
or receive a message, or
do a SQL query, et cetera,
for App 1.
Does that make sense, roughly,
in terms of what's going on?
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Does
the label checking
happen once it gets to that,
or does the reference monitor?
PROFESSOR: Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So the reference monitor,
hugely, importantly,
is in charge of checking
all the permissions that are
represented by these labels.
So you could imagine
different things
going on in terms of
checking the permissions
in the apps themselves.
So why do these guys
actually do the checking
in the reference monitor
instead of in the applications?
Would it make sense to do
the checking in the app?
Suppose we stuck the
label checks into App 1.
Would that be reasonable?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, that
seems like a bad idea,
because if someone
compromises the [INAUDIBLE]
and is able to its behavior
and get past the checking.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right.
So you probably don't want
to stick it in the sender,
because you don't really
want to trust the sender.
So if you install a particular
malicious application,
if you want to be
able to handle,
that application
isn't going to be
guaranteed to do the
correct checks for us.
So that seems a
little unfortunate.
So we're not allowed to do
the checks on the sender site.
What about doing the checks
on the receive side in App 2?
What about that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could, but
it would need crypto,
and you would need a PKI.
So it would be much
more [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you're thinking this would
have to be crypto and have
to have a PKI involved.
So I'm not sure you
have to have crypto,
because the kernel can tell
you exactly where things
are coming from.
So you could still have the
reference monitor telling you,
oh, this is coming from App 1.
So you don't really need
the PKI in that sense.
It doesn't have to
be crypto-related.
I think you need
crypto generally
when you're talking over the
network, when there's nothing
common that you can trust.
Here, I think it's not
so much about crypto.
Any other reasons why you
would actually maybe want it
in that reference monitor?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You might want
to shift the burden away
from the developer,
who ends up making
a lot of mistakes [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
I think a huge part
of it is app bugs.
If you don't really
want silly bugs
that the application
developer makes
to compromise the security.
So to the extent
possible, I think
you want to factor out common
functionality into code
that the developer doesn't
have to worry about so much,
or doesn't even have a
chance of screwing up.
So this seems like partially
a good reason for sticking
to the reference monitor.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It could
also be because you
want to minimize the trusted
surface of the entire system.
So you want to make the
reference monitor so small
that it can actually be
[? orbited ?] on its own,
or have some component that
deals with the actual label
checking that can be
checked on its own.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
So that seems like a
financially reasonable plan
as well, because the
security of the role system
depends on the reference
monitor being correct.
Well, you could see
this going either way.
Actually putting the logic
into the reference monitor
makes the reference
monitor bigger.
So you could make the
RM smaller by delegating
some work to the apps.
Although, then there is some
library you have to audit.
So it's not exactly clear.
I think the one other
example I came up
with for why to do this-- well,
I guess there was two things.
One is just simplicity.
I think it's easier
to do the checks
all in one place in many ways.
So you can sort of-- as you were
saying, that you could really
look at this and say, oh, yup,
the checks are being done.
They're always being
done on every message.
So that's convincing or good
from a software engineering
perspective, perhaps.
Another thing is
that these intents
have two addressing modes.
In particular, in
the paper, they
describe what are called
implicit and explicit intents.
So explicit intents
are ones where
you specify some component.
And you actually
say it has to go
to this particular component.
So for these explicit intents,
it's actually totally fine
to do the checking
on the receiver side,
because well, you know where
you're going to send it.
You can send it there.
And if it doesn't want to
allow you to send the message,
it'll drop it on the floor
or reject it somehow.
But then there's also
implicit intents in Android,
where you don't
know, as a sender,
exactly which application you
want to receive your message.
So this might happen if you
just want to view a picture
or you want to dial
a phone number,
but you don't actually
know which phone
dialer the user has installed.
Maybe it has a Google Voice,
Voice-over IP dialer, or Skype,
or who knows what.
So in those case, these
implicit intents actually
skip the component
name and just say,
I want this action to be
handled with this data
by some application out there.
And in this case, it's the
job of the reference monitor
to find an application
that's suitable for handling
that kind of message--
dialing a phone number,
viewing a PDF, or a JPEG
image, or what have you.
And in that case,
the reference monitor
can actually take
permissions into account
when choosing a
suitable application.
So it might be that there are
some very sensitive PDF viewer
application you have
installed, and it's
capable of viewing
PDFs, but you don't want
it accessible to most apps.
So maybe the permissions on it
don't allow that application
to receive PDF View messages
from the rest of the system.
So in this case, the reference
monitor will look at this
and say, well,
you're not allowed
to send your request there,
but maybe another application
is willing to
handle your request.
So this sort of simplifies
the user interface or user
interaction here by matching
an available system,
including and considering
the permissions that
are available to the sender.
That make sense?
Does that make sense?
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would the reference
monitor ever be a bottleneck?
PROFESSOR: It could be, yeah.
So a lot of these messages
are sent through the reference
monitor.
And I don't know whether it's
actually currently multi-thread
or not.
You probably could
make it multi-thread.
I think the logic
it's implementing
doesn't involve maintaining
a lot of shared state.
So you could probably process
many of intent messages
in parallel if need be.
I suspect that
you could probably
avoid it being a bottleneck.
For bulk things, Android
has an RPC mechanism
that the paper
talks about, where
if you want to send
a lot of operations
to another application,
you actually
send what's called a bind
intent to the reference monitor,
saying, I want a direct
connection to this application.
And if you send a bind intent
to the reference monitor
and it [? forwards the app ?]
to this app,
then you're going to establish
this sort of bound channel
between these two
apps and then send
lots of messages
directly [INAUDIBLE].
So if some
application is worried
about an interface which
is performance-critical,
they'll probably do this.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Why does
the [INAUDIBLE]?
Because every single label
needs to match [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ah.
So here, it's not
the case that you get
direct access inside of App 2.
It's not that you can directly
manipulate all the stuff
in the address space or
the objects of App 2.
You just get a channel
that the other application
is willing to look
at messages of
and do something sensible
with these messages.
So it's up to the Application 2
here to look at these messages
and do something
sensible with them,
not to allow arbitrary code
execution or arbitrary access.
But in this application, I think
they have two operations where
you can add a new friend or
enable or disable tracking
through this interface.
So there's well-defined
messages that you define.
And you're going to
implement probably
one of these [? surface ?]
components that's
responsible for
taking a message,
and checking that it's sensible,
and executing that operation.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Well, so
I guess intents are
usually human-initiated, right?
PROFESSOR: Oftentimes yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And humans are pretty slow.
So it's unlikely that the
reference monitor is going
to be any kind of bottleneck.
PROFESSOR: Yes,
that's probably true.
Yeah.
It depends on exactly, yeah, I
guess how you're using intents.
It's a little bit of a bummer.
In the paper, they say
that the permissions
add [? buying ?] time are
checked by the reference
monitor.
But the permissions on
individual RPC calls
between these
applications are not
checked by the
reference monitor,
because you have this
direct channel between two
applications.
So presumably, actually,
I don't know exactly why
they chose to do it this way.
Perhaps it's to get away from
having a reference monitor be
any kind of bottleneck for
[? handy ?] communication.
But it means that the
permissions for individual RPC
operations between
the applications
have to be done in software
inside of the application
logic, which is a little bit
unfortunate if we want to avoid
the application developer
making these kinds of mistakes
and maybe forgetting to check
the permissions on some RPC
calls.
So in some ways, if you are
purely worried about security,
it might have been nicer
to forward all the RPCs
through the reference
monitor as well,
because then the reference
monitor is going to make sure
that it checks permissions
on every RPC call
instead of just at
the time you establish
a channel for future RPC
calls between two apps.
That make sense?
All right.
OK.
So let's try to figure out-- one
interesting thing [? to do ?]
to try to contrast is, why
did these guys-- before we
dive into a little
bit more details,
why did these guys
design a whole new app
model for Android applications
as opposed to-- we've
seen already.
There's desktop applications,
there's web applications.
Why did these guys
invent a whole new way
of writing software?
Because in some ways, this is
confusing for the developer,
because I am used to
writing my nice little C
program with a main function.
I look at this and say,
well, what the hell?
I mean, what am I
going to do with-- I
have to define four
kinds of components,
and I have to send
intents instead
of just having a C
struct and writing
[? straight line ?] code.
So what are the pros or
cons of existing app models?
So we have, I guess,
desktop apps and web apps.
Why do we need a third
column, so to say?
Because what are the nice
things about these guys?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, the model has
completely changed now, right?
Because I think on
desktop apps, you
don't put as much
trust in the developers
as you put in mobile apps.
And you have a bunch of
more users that are less
[? inexperienced ?] than the
desktop users who end up having
a bunch of apps that really
want to [? isolate ?] from each
other.
PROFESSOR: It could be.
So you think in
the desktop case,
we don't have to trust
the developers as much?
AUDIENCE: Of course you do.
But it seems that there's always
like your son or your cousin
that you take care of their
desktop if it goes bad.
PROFESSOR: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: But with
your phone, there's
a different problem altogether.
PROFESSOR: I guess it's cool
that the phones don't need
a cousin to take care of them.
So that's great, right?
But in terms of security,
one thing on the desktop apps
is that you can't
install-- or it's
really hard to install
new apps or maybe-- well,
probably not quite exactly
true, because you can always
click an executable and install
an app on a desktop case.
But I guess people don't install
apps regularly sort of tend to
maybe-- because it
depends on the usage
model of a desktop app.
But typically, you have
a fixed set of software
you are running as
opposed to on a web app,
one cool thing is that it's
very easy to run new apps.
You just visit a website,
and there's nothing really
you have to do other
than click on a link.
And off you are on some new site
running some new Application.
So that's a pretty nice
property of web apps.
One bummer about desktop
apps is that there's actually
no isolation at all
between applications.
That's perhaps somewhat
related to the fact
that it's hard to
install an app,
because you really
are trusting it
fully with all the
data on your machine
when you're installing it.
There is no isolation
between one app
that you install in your laptop
and probably any other thing
running there, or
any of the data
that you are storing
on that computer.
Whereas in the web
app case, there's
some reasonable isolation.
As long as you believe the
same origin policy is correctly
[INAUDIBLE] by the browser, then
you're in pretty good shape.
It's reasonably safe to probably
go to some arbitrary website
and start using
their application.
It's not going to
tamper with other sites
that you have open
in your browser,
assuming they don't
exploit some browser bugs.
So far, it looks like the web
apps are the winning plan.
They're easy to use,
they have isolation.
Why don't these guys use
web apps for Android?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So web
apps are starting
to become like an operating
system in themselves, right?
So you have Firefox OX, which is
basically just a web mobile OS.
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK.
So you're arguing that actually
these guys were mistaken.
They shouldn't have built
a new Android stack.
They should have just
done a giant web browser
as your phone.
AUDIENCE: Well, at least Mozilla
has shown that it's possible.
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK, fair enough.
So it's at least more reasonable
to go with the web apps
route rather than the desktop
route, at least for phone.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
phone call from a web apps,
you need [? an entire new ?]
API for the web app interface
with the phone.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the one limitation that
might be fixable, of course,
but is still there
is maybe there's
no APIs for some of the devices.
This is increasingly
becoming less so.
Like, for a camera or for
a GPS, these are slowly
being added to the web case.
But there is probably
not quite an API
for accessing your phone
yet, or sending an SMS
message, and things like that.
Another bummer in web apps
is there is actually limited
sharing that you can do.
So we were just talking
about implicit intents
in Android, where you
could just say, well,
I want to view
this JPEG picture,
but who knows what
application's going to open it?
Or I want to view this PDF file.
Or I want to share
this picture I just
took with my camera with
a friend through email,
but I don't know what email
application you're using.
Let's just ask the
reference monitor
to find me some
email program that's
going to send this picture out.
So it's something you can
actually do in Android.
But it's kind of hard
to do in a web app case,
because every
interaction, you have
to refer to a particular URL.
So if you don't know what
PDF viewer someone is using,
you might not know
what URL to open
to ask it to view the PDF
[? potentially. ?] Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But JavaScript is very
hard to read [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So one bummer is that yeah,
this is all JavaScript. [LAUGHS]
So it's potentially unfortunate.
But it's maybe not as good
in terms of performance.
Maybe it's hard to
understand what it's doing.
It might be hard to compile
efficiently, et cetera.
Yeah.
Because one nice thing about
the desktop [INAUDIBLE]
is that sharing is easy.
So one side effect of having
all your files be accessible
in every app is that,
well, you just share.
It's very easy to access
any data you have.
And in some ways, if you
really want a lot of sharing,
this is great.
Like, I probably could-- it
might be a little bit tricky
to implement some things
on Android that are
easy to do in the desktop case.
So in the desktop
case, if I want
to compile a piece of software,
I'm going to run [? Make. ?]
That's going to run GCC
and maybe other programs.
And they're all collaborating
on the same C source
code in the single directory.
They're all building it.
It might be a
little bit trickier
to do in the Android case,
where data is kind of associated
with a primary
application, but storing it
in a [? quantum ?] provider.
So it might be a
little bit tricky
to have an Android world where
I have my source code stored
somewhere, and then I
install a C compiler,
and [? a Make ?] program, and
an assembler, and other things.
And they all sort
of work together.
It's a little bit harder to do.
You probably could
do it somehow.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you could probably work
around it in some ways.
So I think Android is certainly
general purpose enough
to let you somehow do it.
But it's probably not quite as
natural to do this in Android
as it would be in
a desktop case.
Not that I'm arguing
the desktop case.
But it's not quite as secure.
But yeah.
Any other comments?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Another
thing might be the case
that we're optimizing
for different web
apps [INAUDIBLE] constrained.
I'm not sure what [INAUDIBLE]
tend to be constrained by.
But [? web apps ?]
tend to be constrained
by both RAM and processing.
And much more so than either
desktop or web apps, certainly.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it might be that solid
engineering decisions
around how to
optimize these things
are going to be different.
I guess one unfortunate
thing about web apps,
at least at the time these
guys were designing Android,
is that it was difficult
to run a web app offline.
If your phone doesn't have
strong enough cellphone
reception, then it might be hard
for you to run the application
if some parts of it
fell out of the cache.
I think slowly, as
you were pointing out,
the web app world is
catching up to Android.
But many of these
limitations are getting
fixed or sort of improved.
So it might be that
these days, web
apps are a reasonable model for
starting a new phone platform.
But five years ago,
this Android world
was necessary, because the
web apps weren't quite there.
Probably not quite there
still yet, but nowadays,
it might be easier
to push the web apps
all the way to where Android is
rather than start from scratch.
All right.
So I guess we can still
talk about what Android
did even though maybe
today you wouldn't
have done it the same way.
But I guess in
terms of isolation,
we can start talking maybe about
security a little bit more.
Android relies on
the Linux kernel,
as I mentioned, to isolate
these apps from one another.
So what happens is that the
Android framework actually
sets user IDs so that this
application has perhaps
UID 1,001.
This application
runs as UID 1,002.
And the reference monitor
is basically [INAUDIBLE].
So I think it
might run as UID 0,
although I forget the detail.
But I think it does run
as UID 0 on Android.
So the Linux kernel is largely
responsible for keeping
the apps separate
from one another.
And mostly, interactions
between user IDs
happens through these intents.
And then there's a little bit
of details in terms of things
that the Linux kernel
actually enforces
in terms of which UID is allowed
to do which operation as well.
So we'll talk about
that in a second.
One interesting question is
why did these guys choose Java?
Like, what's the role
of Java in Android?
Why is Java there at all?
Is it enforcing anything?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think it
enforces [? text messaging ?]
and [? downstreaming. ?]
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK.
So what do we get out of it?
Is it like for security,
for probability?
One other way to think of
it is suppose we took away
Java and made all the
apps written in C,
or, like, Assembly, or
don't require anything
at all for that matter.
Would anything break?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You have
vulnerabilities [INAUDIBLE]
override these important values.
PROFESSOR: Uh-huh.
Yeah, it could be.
So like an app could have
some buffer overflow in it.
So how bad would that be?
AUDIENCE: It could
override with permissions.
PROFESSOR: Which permissions?
AUDIENCE: Like the latency.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, actually, let's see.
So as we were talking
about, the reference monitor
is the thing that does all
the label checking for us.
And the reference
monitor actually,
in Android, stores a list of
all the installed applications
along with the labels
that correspond
to all those applications.
So it's probably
true that you don't
want any kinds of bugs
in the reference monitor
regardless of what
language it's written in.
So having the
reference monitor being
written in a type-safe
language is probably
a good thing in general.
And I like Java.
I can sense that it's
a type-safe language
and has all these
nice properties.
But if an application
were to be written in C
and had a buffer
overflow, it wouldn't
be able to corrupt directly the
labels stored in the reference
monitor here.
So that wouldn't be
as big of a deal.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It could be.
So why would that be helpful?
AUDIENCE: There's some
system [INAUDIBLE] that it
can actually override C?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So in principle, it
might be nice to avoid
the applications talking
directly to the Linux kernel.
[INAUDIBLE] in Android,
this is not the case.
So actually,
Android applications
can make arbitrary system
calls if they want to.
And in fact,
applications I should say
can shift with
arbitrary components
written in C or Assembly
for performance reasons.
So some games [? shift ?] with
the computationally intensive
parts written in
C. And they sort of
talk to it from Java as well.
AUDIENCE: So I
guess part of it is
being able to use all
of the stuff that's
been written for Java.
They wanted to make
it easy to build
applications for developers.
And one of the easy
ways of doing that
is being able to take advantage
of the massive Java libraries
out there.
PROFESSOR: Mm-hm.
Yeah.
So I think one big reason for
using Java is the usability.
They wanted to-- I think Java
has little to do with security
and mostly with programmability,
ease of development.
One other thing that
I think is going on
is that-- well, to contrast
with iPhones, for example.
iPhones also really want
ease of development.
But they use Objective C, which
has buffer overflows if you
try hard enough.
And it is specific to
a particular hardware.
It doesn't maybe have
all the same libraries.
I think the main reason
why the Android guys
went with Java is
probably the fact
that they weren't manufacturing
devices at the same time.
So the iPhones
knew exactly it was
going to be this ARM
processor running their phone.
So they could compile to
ARM and be done with it.
And it's more efficient,
because battery
matters a lot on a phone.
And the Android guys use Java,
which probably is slightly
less power-efficient or
CPU-efficient, because it
involves this JRE, et cetera.
But the cool thing
about it, it's
actually portable
between architectures.
So if you have a phone that
has a MIPS processor, or an ARM
processor, or an x86
processor, the Java application
can be run on all three
of these kinds of devices.
And the Android guys
wanted their platform
to be usable on any kind
of hardware or phone.
So that's probably
one big reason
for why they use Java
in all these cases,
and probably less so in
terms of [? staying ?]
security consideration for Java.
So in fact, it turns out that
the Java runtime doesn't really
provide any security purpose
for the application and is just
sort of a nice
convenience thing,
as well as providing all the
abstractions that the developer
should think in terms of.
But in terms of
isolation, it's mostly
up to the kernel and
the reference monitor
to keep these guys in line.
That make sense?
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't the
ease of development also
kind of translate into
some security [INAUDIBLE]?
Because if you write that
reference monitor in C,
I can see much more
ways to make a mistake.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you're absolutely right.
Actually, I shouldn't have
said that ease of development
has nothing to do with security.
This is completely
silly, because you
want to make it as easy as
possible to write correct code.
And it's all about
covering mistakes.
So in some ways,
having a system where
it's easy to write correct code
is the most important security
consideration to have.
So in some sense, you're
right, that it avoids the bugs.
But you don't want your
application written in C.
Or I don't know why Apple has
Objective C. It's actually
a little bit of a
problem in this regard,
because you could
easily have buffer
overflows in your application.
And if that application
matters a lot,
then it's vulnerable
potentially.
Not with respect to compromising
other applications, but you're
[? all like, ?] bank
app, I don't want
that bank app written in C.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the reference
monitor written in Java or C?
PROFESSOR: So in Android, the
reference monitor is largely
written in Java, yes.
There are some native hooks
that it needs in order
to be able to talk to these
intent interface-- pipes,
basically, to talk
to the binder,
they need some native code.
They need some native code
to spawn these applications
in the first place, et cetera.
But by and large, most of
the logic is written in Java.
So it's actually a reasonably
safe plan, I think.
Any other questions about this?
All right.
So I guess let's try to figure
out what are these application
UIDs used for other than
to keep applications
separate from another in
terms of their processes?
So I guess the main
thing that applications
need to use the UID for or
that we need to somehow support
is the ability to share access
to shared resources and shared
data in the system.
And we already saw one
mechanism for doing it,
which is to send intents
to the reference monitor.
But there's a bunch of things
that, in Android, are not
done through intents to
the reference monitor.
And they have to do
probably with performance,
or why-- basically, why isn't
everything sent through intents
is probably because there
are some performance
considerations.
You don't want to
invoke the reference
monitor in every single
thing you do in the system.
And there's a couple of things
that an Android are like this.
The simplest one is
probably network access.
So if you want to
talk to the internet,
you just open a
socket, very much
like you would on a standard
Linux application today.
The application can just ask
the kernel, I want a socket,
I want to connect
to this machine.
Go for it.
So network access
happens to work this way.
Access to removable storage.
So if you have an SD
card in your phone,
that also directly goes
through the kernel.
Or more generally, any
kind of file system access
or direct access to the
file system, at least,
goes directly
through the kernel,
because there is already
a file system there.
And you want to avoid probably
[INAUDIBLE] performance
overheads on that.
And also, for most
devices that are hardware,
Android allows the application
to directly talk to the device
instead of mediating the access
through the reference monitor.
So this is things like probably
your camera, your GPS device,
compass, et cetera.
And these guys just show up in
Android in Linux as something
like /dev/camera.
And this is just
a Linux device you
could open, and get the
camera data out, and control
the camera in whatever
ways you want, et cetera.
And the cool thing is that if
you want to do some specialized
things to this device,
you're not restricted
to what Java allows you to do.
You can always
write C code or even
Assembly that directly
talks to the kernel
and performs the necessary
operations on this Linux
device, making
arbitrary system calls.
And you could wrap this up
in a Java native interface
to expose it to the rest of your
Java-based application here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But you still have the
checks in these calls, right?
So when you open
a socket, someone
has to check if they're allowed
to open a socket [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is an interesting thing.
Now these things are outside
our intent-based model.
So how are we going
to protect these guys?
So this sort of boils
down to doing something
very similar to
what you guys did
in Lab 2, which is
you [INAUDIBLE] you
want to enforce it using UIDs.
Basically, the
Android framework is
responsible for carefully
orchestrating the UIDs and GIDs
of the applications
and of these things
to enforce whatever policy was
specified in terms of labels.
So the way this works
out is that for every one
of these resources, there
is a pre-defined label
string that defines
the privilege
to access this resource.
So for this network
access thing,
for example, I think
there's a string, something
like
android.permissions.INTERNET.
So this is a label that an
application can ask for.
And if an application has this
label in its set of privileges,
then it should be able
to access the network.
And the way this is
enforced-- so the label
is the policy side of this.
How do you specify
what should happen?
And the enforcement
mechanism is a small change
to the Linux kernel in
Android, where in order
to make any network-related
system calls,
you have to be a member
of some magic group.
This is not at all how things
work in Linux traditionally.
But in Android, there is
some magic group [INAUDIBLE]
I think it's GID 3003.
And the kernel has this
number hard-coded in it.
And if the process has this
group ID in its group list,
then it's allowed to use a
network-related system call.
And if it doesn't have this
group ID in its group list,
then it's not allowed to make
any network-related system
calls at all.
So this is how Android is able
to translate these label--
sort of maintain a single,
coherent policy system that's
in terms of these label
screens, but enforce it
in different ways.
So sometimes it gets enforced
by the reference monitor.
And other times,
it gets enforced
by setting GIDs or
UIDs appropriately.
The same thing actually
happens with SD cards.
There's another GID that
corresponds to having access
with the SD card.
And there's a string that
gets translated into this GID,
effectively.
And same for the file system.
I guess in the
file system, things
are a little bit trickier.
I guess the SD card
is in the file system
and has a specific GID for
accessing the entire SD card.
Another sort of other files
in the phone's file system--
there, the policy isn't
so much controlled
by labels, but rather
by Android's design,
which is that each application
has a private directory
that it can use to store
whatever files it wants.
And in particular,
the content provider,
the SQL database that you're
going to use as an application,
is stored in your
private directory.
And the policy is only the
application's UID can access
that private directory,
and no one else
can access it directly.
And then for
devices, there's also
a plan very similar to
network access, where
there's a permission string
for accessing GPS, the camera,
et cetera.
And for each one
of these, there's
a GID that is used in the
permissions on that device.
So for example, dev/camera
is owned by some magic GID.
And any application that should
have access to that camera
has that GID in its [INAUDIBLE].
All make sense?
It was hopefully fairly similar
to what you guys did in Lab 2.
Well, not the label part,
but the using UIDs and GIDs
to get somewhere [INAUDIBLE].
Make sense?
All right.
So one interesting question
is why do these guys
have such a course-grained
plan for handling the SD card?
Why don't they
have different apps
act [? with ?] different
parts of the SD card?
I probably have lots
of stuff in my SD card
that I don't want
applications to-- you know,
to have access to all of it.
Make sense?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe it has
something to do with [INAUDIBLE]
that a user has to
approve those permissions.
And the less of them you
have, the more likely
it is to actually [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Could be.
Well, that's definitely a
problem in general in Android,
and we'll get to it in a minute.
But I think for the
SD card, it's actually
a slightly different concern.
It has to do with
the fact that you
want these SD cards
to inter-operate
with the rest of the world.
So this is like
one of the places
where Android isn't free to
make arbitrary decisions,
because you want these SD
cards to have a standard file
system, namely
FAT, because that's
the de facto standard for
storing data on an SD card
these days.
And as a result, you can't have
a sophisticated file system
there that stores
permissions for each file.
And as a result, it's
going to be difficult
for you to somehow
segregate these files
and give different
apps different access.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you still
think of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it might be that you
could give each application
a different subdirectory on
the SD card to have access to.
But then it would
mostly be a way
to give each application
additional storage and not
the ability for an
application to read existing
content from your SD card.
Because the existing
content might
be in some other directory.
So you're right.
It might be that you could
have more fine-grained things,
like well, you want access to
the entire SD card addressed
to a per app directory there.
And that probably has to
do with not overwhelming
the user with too many choices
in terms of these permissions.
But yeah, you're right,
you could probably
do some combination
of these two.
All right.
So I guess one
interesting [? thing to ?]
talk about is how do we decide
whether an application should
have a particular set of labels
that it should have access
to in this label set?
So where do these guys
actually come from?
Like, who decides that
this application should
have DIAL PERM and
INTERNET and FRIEND VIEW
permissions in Android?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The
developer [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
a little bit of a,
you know, well, I guess
an upfront system, where
the developer has
to, first of all,
enumerate all the things
it'll ever need in the future
or as their applications
going to run.
And then the user is responsible
for looking over this list
and deciding whether
it's OK, whether they
should allow these application
to be installed or not.
And this way, the user is
still an important part
of the system in
terms of security,
because the user
could almost always
approve any set of
permissions you want
or that the developer wants.
So in many ways, it's
actually quite flexible,
because unlike something like
iOS-- where it's actually
difficult to share between
apps, or it's hard,
for example, for a third-party
iPhone application,
I think, to access arbitrary
other components of the phone,
and dial a phone, or
send an SMS message,
or find a JPEG viewer,
et cetera-- here,
it's quite flexible.
But sort of the cost
to it is that you
have to get the
developer or the user
to check that the
developer is asking
for a sensible set of
permissions or the user
trusts this developer
with these privileges.
So it's a little
bit unfortunate.
It's probably one of
the biggest, actually,
security problems in
practice with Android,
which is that users are
quite willing to give away
these permissions if they
really want an application.
I search for some application,
and I click Install.
And if it doesn't look like
a particularly long list
and there's nothing that
pops out right away,
I'll probably click OK.
And I might not spend the
time to really understand
whether these permissions
are necessary.
The other slight bummer is that
[INAUDIBLE] the time this paper
was written, Android
decided that the user
had only two choices--
either install the app
or not install the app,
which is a little bit
of a binary choice.
And the user is presumably
going to just say, well, yeah,
I want the app.
What else am I going to do?
I need to do this thing.
And I think more recently, I
think some version of Android,
I think 4.3, introduced
a more fine-grain scheme,
where the user is actually
allowed to pick and choose
from these permissions where--
well, you are still presented
with a list of permissions
that the developer wants
for their application to have.
But the user can now, in a
more fine-grained manner,
remove some of these permissions
from the application.
And it's unclear how an average
user is supposed to use this,
because it's probably quite
hard to go through this list
and make decisions about this.
But at least the API is
starting to show up there.
I haven't seen any
significant uses of it so far.
But it might be nice.
All right.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
it just lets you take away.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The [INAUDIBLE] just
lets you take away [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I think that's basically
what this new version of Android
lets you do, which is you can--
instead of taking away-- well,
it's not labelled strings.
It's descriptions of
these permissions.
But you can actually
now-- something, I think,
called Android Permission
Manager lets you,
for every app, list
all the labeled strings
that the app has permission for.
And you could, I think,
remove these things
on an individual basis if
you feel strongly about them.
I don't know how many
users [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Whenever the labels
[? don't match up, ?] does it
hard-fail, or is it just that
doesn't work [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well,
I think it depends
on exactly what
the application is
trying to do that is going
to require that label.
So if the application is
going to send an intent
and sending that intent requires
a particular label like DIAL
PERM, well, it
might be that you're
going to send the intent
to the reference monitor.
And the reference
monitor is going
to say, well, there's
no application that is
willing to accept your message.
So maybe then it's
up to the application
to do something
sensible in response.
Another possibility is that
maybe it's a network access,
and you don't have
access to that,
and you're going to make
a socket system call,
or you're going to say,
connect to this IP address.
And the kernel says, E
PERM, you can't do that.
And who knows what
the application
is going to do in that case?
Maybe it'll throw a null
pointer exception somehow.
So one argument
against doing this
is that Android applications,
at least originally,
weren't written to expect
some of their accesses
to fail, because they were told,
the manifest is all or nothing.
Either the user approves
your app, or they don't.
So application developers,
perhaps rightly so,
wrote code that
perhaps crashes or does
something not unexpected if
some access provision fails.
So it might be that by
taking away permissions,
you're going to cause the app to
crash if it needs that access.
So it's not like, well, you
know, you have this nice app,
and it needs access
to the camera.
But if you turn it off, it'll
just put on some dummy picture
instead.
Maybe it'll just crash instead.
So it's not great.
You might imagine much
more sophisticated systems
which, if you take away some
of the access to a camera,
are going to provide a
fake camera that just has
a black screen all the time.
So this is not
what Android does.
But you could imagine
[? alternate ?] situations
where this might happen.
All right.
Any other questions here?
So we've looked a
little bit at sort
of where these strings come from
in the label of an Android app.
But who defines these strings?
Like, where does the meaning
of a string come from?
You can list all kinds of
strings in your manifest file.
But how do you decide
which strings matter?
Where does this string
INTERNET or FRIEND VIEW
come from in the first place?
Who gives it meaning
in the system?
Any ideas?
Well, I think it's
mostly-- the way
to think of it is that
almost none of these strings
should be magic or
pre-defined ahead of time.
Almost all these
strings are basically
contracts between
two applications
so one application is
willing to export something
under the protection
of some label string.
And another application wants
to ask for that permission
to talk to the application
that defines this component.
So these labels
are typically-- you
can think of them
as being defined
by the application that
provides some protected service.
So if you have this
DIAL PERM permission,
it's presumably
something that has
to be defined by an application
that defines what it
means to dial a phone number.
So probably the dialer
application in your phone,
that's the thing that defines
the string and says that, yeah,
this thing, DIAL PERM,
exists, and my components
are going to be protected by it.
And then other
applications that want
to interact with this
guy, with the dialer,
can now request this DIAL PERM
permission for themselves.
And of course, there
are some built-in things
that we looked at here, like the
internet permission, the camera
permission, et cetera.
But you can sort
of think of them
as the Android framework being
the initial application that
is in charge of providing
access to this resource
and defining the string
that's going to protect
the resource as well.
What does it mean?
What's sort of associated with
a label string in Android other
than the fact that the string
goes into the application's
label here when they want
to ask for this permission
and in the component
label as well?
So there's a couple of
things that is associated
with the label in Android.
So a label, in
addition to a string,
also has a couple of
interesting properties.
So there's a type of a label.
And there's, at least in
sort of a modern Android,
there's three types
you might care about.
There's a normal type of a
label, or permission label.
There's dangerous and signature.
And the application that
defines this permission
in the first place gets
to choose the type or all
these other fields for
a label that we're going
to talk about in a second.
So what's the point
of a type of a label?
Why do labels have
types in Android?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I guess so.
Yeah.
So why not make everything
dangerous, I guess,
at that level?
Well, I guess, yeah.
So maybe the interesting
thing is like,
what are the semantics
of these types?
So if something is dangerous,
then you are right.
It actually warns
the users when you're
installing an application,
and the application
asks for access to a particular
label that's of type Dangerous.
Then the user has to
look at this message
and say, yes, I'm willing to
give this dangerous permission
to this new application.
For normal-type labels,
applications can ask for them,
and the user
doesn't get prompted
if the application requests
this normal type of permission.
Is this silly?
What's the point of a permission
if everyone just gets it?
Is there a reason why
we should have this?
Like, one example of a
normal permission in Android
is setting your wallpaper.
So if you have an
application that's
going to set your wallpaper,
I can, as an application
developer, say in
my manifest that I
want to set your wallpaper.
And if you click
Install, it's going
to say, well, there's nothing
interesting going on here.
You don't need to give
it any permissions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, these
permissions usually require you
to [INAUDIBLE], right?
So if an application wants to
change your desktop wallpaper,
it will ask you.
The system will ask you, do you
want to change your wallpaper?
PROFESSOR: Nope.
AUDIENCE: No?
PROFESSOR: No, it'll just
change the wallpaper.
It's access to this API call
to change the wallpaper.
If I have this permission,
I can make this API call.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe the application
developer wants to make sure
they don't do this accidentally?
PROFESSOR: Yes, I think that's
one reason why you might want
to have these permissions,
is to help the application
developer do the right thing.
So if you worry that your
application might accidentally
do something or it
might have bugs in it
that others will
exploit, knowing
that there's some
set of permissions
that you do or don't have
prevents your application
from being abused in these ways.
So if you have a
benign application that
never needs to
set the wallpaper,
you probably don't want to
ask for this permission,
because if a VLAN
gets compromised,
then it will be
better for the user,
on whose phone your
application's installed.
It's sort of a least
privilege property.
I guess another thing
is that it maybe
allows some sort of auditing,
both from a developer
standpoint, where
they can look and see,
well, what are the things I
should be concerned about here?
And as well as from
a user's perspective.
If your phone is flickering
with a wallpaper change
every second, you can go and
see who has this permission.
Even though I didn't
have to approve it,
I can at least go and
check who is potentially
doing this right now.
So these normal
permissions are kind of
like a good security
measure-- or probably more
of a good auditing measure.
And [? aren't ?] generally used
for really interesting things
like [INAUDIBLE] data or
accessing things like cameras
or things that cost money.
So there's also this third
thing, this signature
permission.
So one interesting
thing in Android
is that you can define
a permission that
is only accessible to
applications that are signed
with the same developer
key as the application that
defined the permission
in the first place.
So if I have, I guess in
the FRIEND VIEW example
in the paper, if the friend
tracker defined some permission
with this signature type,
then only other applications
signed by the same
developer key are
going to be able to get
this signature permission.
What's the point of this thing?
Why not just make them
dangerous or, I don't know,
something else?
Why do we need a third type?
Any reason?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Operations
[INAUDIBLE] same developer?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it might be that
this developer has
some internal APIs that
they don't actually mean
to expose to the outside world.
But they just want to couple
their own applications
to each other.
So maybe Facebook,
hypothetically,
could write multiple
applications.
They might have one
application that's
pre-fetching content
from Facebook servers,
another application that
fuses, another application that
tracks your location.
And they want all
these components
to interact with one another.
And they can define the
signature permission
to do this.
And presumably, one reason why
you might not want to do this--
might not want to
tag this permission
as a dangerous permission is
for mostly the same reasons
as the [INAUDIBLE]
was talking about,
which is that if you really know
who should be allowed to get
this permission, you don't
want to allow the user
to screw this up.
So the user could always
be tricked by someone--
or could be tricked by
someone into accepting
a malicious application that
asks for some permission that's
really dangerous.
But [? it doesn't ?]
need to be dangerous,
you could just define
this signature.
And the user doesn't
even have a choice
of giving away
some application's
internal privileges.
That's one nice thing
about this permission type.
Make sense?
So there's other
stuff associated
with the label that mostly
has to do with describing
the permission to the user.
So there's some sort
of a description here
that is the sort of
English-level explanation
of what this permission entails.
And it's this
description that pops up
when you're asked to
install a new application.
So the Android framework will
look through all the label
strings in the manifest
of the application you're
about to install, and display
to the user the descriptions
for all those labeled
strings, saying, OK,
you're about to give away the
privileges to dial your phone,
or you're about to give this
application the permission
to send SMS messages on
your behalf, et cetera.
That make sense?
All right.
So one interesting
question is, what
happens if a malicious
application defines
a label for some other app?
These labels are just
free-form strings.
So what happens if you're
a malicious application
and you say, oh, I have
this new, great permission.
It's called DIAL PERM.
And [INAUDIBLE] dangerous.
And the description
does nothing.
Is it good or [INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
domains [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you hope so.
Unfortunately, it's
not actually enforced.
So by convention, all
these permission strings
should have Java-style
reversed domain names.
But there's no
strict association
between the labels that
an application defines
and the application's
own Java-style name.
And for that matter,
there's nothing
that enforces that an
application's Java-style name
be tied to anything, because
we have no way of knowing
whether the public
[INAUDIBLE] developer signing
a particular
application corresponds
to com.google.something
or edu.mit.something.
So in fact, one slight
weakness in Android
that was there at least when
I checked a while ago-- it
probably is still there-- is
that the label definitions are
sort of first
come, first served.
So when you first
install an application,
it defines a
particular label, you
get to decide what type
that label string is
and what is the description
of this label string.
So for system permissions, this
is probably not a big problem,
because the system
permissions, or the ones
for built-in applications
like [? compiler, ?]
get defined first.
But applications that come later
are unable to redefine them.
So at least the
framework enforces that.
But certainly, one bummer
is that if you install
a malicious application
first and then
some important
application later,
the malicious application
can potentially
subvert the labels used by
the later well-meaning app.
So in the paper's
FRIEND VIEWER example,
you could actually-- if you're
a malicious developer, you could
first trick the
user into installing
these applications defines
this FRIEND [? VIEW ?]
permission to be a normal
permission with a description
stream saying, oh, this does
nothing interesting at all.
And then the FRIEND VIEWER
applet gets installed later.
It can't redefine this label.
It's already been defined.
And consequently might
be unable to prevent
the user from giving
away this FRIEND VIEW
permission to other apps.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, in principle,
the framework could do this.
When I tried this, you
don't get warned at all.
So if you install
an application that
defines a label that's already
been defined, it does nothing.
It simply ignores the
VIEW label definition
and uses the old one.
Perhaps that's the problem
where it really goes wrong.
You should at least
say, well, I refuse
to install this application,
because it's defining
a label that already exists.
AUDIENCE: Owned by
this other application.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And it's owned by a
different key even.
Yeah.
So at least there's a chance
to fix this potentially.
I haven't seen this
fixed yet, but maybe I've
not been keeping track of it.
Anyway.
So that's kind of an
interesting problem
that you really have to
keep track of these names
and figure out who owns a
name and getting that right
is actually quite important.
So one interesting problem
that shows up in Android
has to do with these broadcast
receivers or sort of sending
messages between applications.
So one interesting problem is
when you're sending-- well,
I guess I should first describe
how these messages work
with broadcast receivers.
So broadcast receivers are
used for one application
being able to
announce some event
to every other
application in the system.
So as we saw before,
intents typically
go to a particular component,
like view a JPEG image.
But for some events,
like, the system boots up.
Or my friends are nearby.
You might want to announce
this to every application that
cares.
And this is what these
broadcast receivers are for.
But you actually
start worrying when
you have these messages being
sent between two applications,
both in the broadcast receiver
case and in other cases,
you probably care
about two things.
You might want to
authenticate where
the message is coming from.
So you want to know
who sent this message.
Can I trust them?
And also, you want to
potentially control
where this message
goes to-- who is
able to receive this message.
And initially, it seems like
an Android device didn't quite
get these things quite
correctly in several ways.
In particular, the
broadcast receivers--
well, if you are sending
a broadcast message
to all the other
components in your system,
I think in the initial
version of Android,
you just sent this message.
And other applications could
either subscribe or not
subscribe to these messages.
So if you have a FRIEND
VIEWER application that it'll
subscribe to these messages
by setting the right action
or date or data time or MIME
type in their Intent filter,
but most applications
could always
subscribe to all broadcast
events in the system.
And you are able
to watch everything
that's going on on the
phone, or everything
that's being broadcast.
So the Android framework added
an extra sort of argument
for applications to
be able to specify
who should be able to
see a broadcast message.
So when you're sending
a broadcast message,
there's the obvious
argument, which
is the message you want to send,
which is basically an intent.
But then you can also
specify an optional label
that describes who should be
able to receive this message.
So instead of broadcasting
to everyone in the system,
you can say, well, only
other applications that
have a certain permission
should be able to receive
this broadcast message from me.
So this way, you could send
out sensitive information,
like the locations
of your friends,
in the paper's
example, and make sure
that only those
applications that
are allowed to see the
list of your friends
will actually get your
broadcast message.
So this is how, on
Android, you can actually
control who receives the
message that you're sending out,
at least in the broadcast case.
Question?
No. [? Sorry. ?]
How do you authenticate
where a message is actually
coming from?
So suppose that in
Android, you register
for-- in the paper's example,
you have your FRIEND VIEWER
and you receive
a message saying,
yep, this friend is nearby.
How do you know this actually
came from the right component?
Can you actually convince
yourself of this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Using
the kernel codes?
Wouldn't you trust the
kernel [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Potentially, yeah.
Well, this binder thing is going
to tell the reference monitor,
here's where the
intent came from.
And then the
reference monitor is
going to forward this intent
to your receiver application.
And somewhere in
there is the name
of the applet that
sent this guy.
How should you
check whether this
is a reasonable app that should
be sending these intents?
Is there a way to
do this in Android?
I guess you're right.
Strictly speaking, yeah, the
source is always authenticated.
You know exactly which
app sent the message.
But what do you do
with a source name?
How do you check whether
it should be sending
these Friend is Near messages?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
label [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So one way to do it
is to actually stick
a label on the
broadcast receiver.
So one thing you could is say,
well, the only people that
are allowed to send a message
to the broadcast receiver
are people with the Friend
Tracker maybe label.
So if you stick such a label
on your broadcast receiver,
then you know that only
messages sent from applications
with this label are going to get
to you through your broadcast
receiver.
That's one way to filter who's
able to send messages to you is
by restricting them by label.
So this works in many cases.
Android also provides a
more specific function
that you can use.
It's called Check Privilege.
And you could sort of say--
or Check Sender Privilege,
I think.
And you could ask the
framework whether the sender
of the intent you're looking
at has a certain label
in its provisions.
So this way, you can also
reason about what privileges
does the sender of
a particular message
have in situations where maybe
the framework doesn't provide
quite the right mechanisms
in the manifest to do this.
One place where this Check
Sender Privilege function
turns out to be
particularly useful
is in the case of this RPC
interaction between two
applications, where the
reference monitor isn't
actually involved in mediating
the RPC-looking applications.
But you still want to
ask, is the application
of [INAUDIBLE] privileged
for this kind of operation?
So this way, you can
manually invoke-- or check
what's in the manifest
of an application.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, so I
guess-- [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You can use the
signature to enable it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
one thing that stops
is presumably the [INAUDIBLE].
If the label is a
signature type label,
then that's going to stop
it if it's not [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: That requires
the same signature as--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah, yeah.
So that requires it be
the same, exact developer.
Another thing that stops it is
that maybe the permission is
labelled as Dangerous.
So then the user is going
to see this on their screen.
When you install an
app, it says, this app
requires the permission
of viewing your friends,
or your friends' locations.
AUDIENCE: But that's taken
from the description.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: So what's
[INAUDIBLE] from just giving
a different description?
PROFESSOR: So I should
say, this description
comes from the application that
initially defines this label.
So the label is initially--
so there's two things going on
in the manifest.
You can ask for access
to existing labels.
So I can say, well,
this is an application.
I want access to the
FRIEND VIEW permission.
And a separate thing you can
do in the manifest is say,
I am defining a
new kind of label.
So then the first Friend
Viewer application--
or the Friend Tracker
application, presumably,
is going to say, well,
I have an application,
it has these permission.
But also, I'm defining
a new kind of label.
It's called this.
It's type Dangerous, and
it has this description.
So that's a place where
you have to really get
the-- this is that first
come, first served problem.
But as long as the application
that should define the label
is installed first, then
you're in good shape.
Any subsequent application
is going to ask for the label
just by its string name.
And then the Android
framework will fish out
the description and the
type from the application
that first defined it.
All right.
Any other questions here?
So I guess this gives you some
sense of how Android works.
So one cool thing about it
is that you can actually
get this manifest that,
to a larger extent,
describes the security
properties of an application.
So this is one thing that
the developers of the Android
framework were going
for-- something called
mandatory access control,
where you can actually specify
the security policy of
an application separate
from the application
itself, and in fact,
have that security policy be
enforced by this reference
monitor regardless of what that
application itself is doing.
So it seems like kind
of a nice property
to be able to audit an
application by looking
at this manifest file.
You can mostly think of it as a
development nicety rather than
a strict enforcement mechanism,
because if an application
really wants to get
around its own manifest,
it can probably do so.
But it seems like
a nice way of being
able to understand what's going
on with an application in terms
of security without having to
dive down into the Java code.
Of course, it matters,
but you can still
get a high-level sense of what's
going on in an application
from the manifest.
One bummer, I guess, as we
were talking about here,
there are some situations where
the Android framework turns out
to be not quite expressive
enough in the manifest.
And you have to
still write code that
talks about security checks.
It would be, in some ways,
nice if there were no security
checks at all in the code
and all the security checks
went to the manifest.
But that would mean exposing
things like all the RPCs
to the framework and so on.
That's potentially
a bit of a trade-off
that these guys are making.
And I guess one other
thing is it's actually
kind of hard to change
the manifest file
after you design the system.
So one perhaps
surprising thing is
that the Android
framework hasn't changed
in terms of security very
much since it was released
or since this paper was
written five years ago, or six
years ago now.
Because once the application
starts using this framework,
it's hard to say some existing
application's going to break.
So you basically
have to maintain
backwards compatibility
to a large extent.
So you don't get a chance
to sort of do it over again.
I guess one
interesting thing that
did happen to Android
since this paper came out
is that the Android guys
borrowed an idea from Apple
and are doing now much
more server-side analysis
of applications.
So Apple, on the iPhone side,
is pretty aggressive in terms
of having the Apple server
checking all the applications
from developers for
various guidelines,
including security properties.
And the Android servers, or
this Android market or whatever,
now also does quite a bit
of analysis of applications
submitted by developers
to make sure they are not
malicious in some loose sense.
So that's kind of a cool thing.
And it is largely
[? orthogonal ?]
to this security architecture.
So this security architecture
works on your phone.
But then for any other
security problems,
the server can evolve
defenses over time as need be.
And those tend to be more
on the phishing side, where
the human is being tricked
into doing something
rather than on exploiting
some specific vulnerability
in the kernel,
perhaps, and so on.
Make sense?
Any other questions?
All right.
So we'll see you guys
on Wednesday, hopefully.
We'll talk about an extension
of Android for data privacy.